the statement we bill we don't make we
don't build services to make money we
make money to build better services
really goes to the heart of the
philosophy that we haven't running the
company and you know there's no doubt we
are a mission driven company i mean we
exist and we wake up in the morning and
the thing that gets us excited is making
the world we're open and connected and
the things that we're doing to build
that but you know you can't just focus
on that right i mean since the beginning
of building facebook what one of the
core things that um that I've learned is
that you know in order to do this we
have to build a great team and in order
to build a great team you know the best
people want to work on a mission that
they believe in but they also want to
make a bunch of money right in order to
do that you have to build a great
business we want to build a platform
right in order to build a platform we
need to build tools that are going to
make it so that developers can build the
things that they want and make a bunch
of money and in order to do that we need
to have a business model that works for
them and incentivizes them to want to
work with us advertisers produce a lot
of the content right i mean a lot of
what people do on facebook is around
pages that content is in the system
because advertisers get a good ROI
working with facebook so building a
mission and building a business go hand
in hand and um it is definitely true
that the primary thing that that makes
me excited about what we're doing is the
mission but i also think that from the
very beginning we've had this healthy
understanding which is that we need to
do both and we're about doing both and
that that's a key part of understanding
the philosophy that we have